Okay.
So there is a new poll released yesterday
which shows Bernie Sanders ahead of President
Donald Trump by nine percentage points in
a hypothetical 2020 matchup and Joe Biden
ahead of Trump by 10 percentage points in
a similar hypothetical 2020 matchup.
This if even slightly accurate, is incredible,
but we've got some caveats.
The first caveat, which will be very clear
to many in our audience is that a Fox News
poll is the source of this information and
I know that that will immediately make many
people on the left not trusted.
The funny thing is that very same fact that
it is a Fox News poll is making a lot of the
American right wing very nervous because they
tend to trust Fox News and they're now stuck
in a cognitively dissonant spot between a
rock and a hard place, so to speak.
The truth is that every one of these poles
has a margin of error and the Fox News poll
is not drastically out of line with what other
polls are finding.
Although, yes, the leads, the deficits that
Donald Trump has according to this latest
poll are bigger than in most other polls.
You have to remember that at this point there
are also lots of undecided, so the plus 10
that Biden has in the plus nine that Bernie
has, a lot of that is because there are people
who have not yet decided, many of whom, many
of whom will eventually break for the incumbent.
So if anybody thinks that Donald Trump is
going to lose the popular vote by 10 percentage
points in November of 2020, uh, that is extraordinarily
unlikely to happen.
Uh, and remember that we are still 500 days
from the election and these are only hypothetical
matchups because we don't actually know who
is going to be running against Donald Trump
as the winner of the Democratic primary.
This will all start to get more representative
of what we can expect in November of 2020.
Once the democratic debates begin, once all
of those one and two percenters start to drop
out, and that support starts to shift to other
Democratic candidates when Trump starts campaigning.
There's a lot here that is going to happen
soon.
And I want to mention something else that's
funny.
Along these lines, I saw a discussion on a
subreddit.
I'm not even going to tell you which sub reddit
because I don't want to give it any publicity.
This poll showing Trump down so bigly to Biden
and to, to uh, uh, Bernie Sanders.
It's sort of pierced the echo chamber because
when it came out they came up with an amazing
post hoc rationalization.
I want to try to explain it clearly because
I really you to understand what it is that
they are trying to say in response to this
pole.
It's just so wacky.
The reaction was Fox News faked the poll results
because Fox News wants Biden to win and the
reason Fox News once Biden to win is that
Fox News is right wing.
They want war with Iran.
Trump now says he doesn't want war with Iran.
Joe Biden will go to war with Iran.
So now the pro war right wing propaganda apparatus
wants Biden to defeat Trump so that Biden
will take us to a big war with Iran, which
is why Fox News has decided to turn on Trump
and foe publish fake polls that show Biden
winning.
Now, aside from the fact that that entire
conspiracy theory is not based in any fact,
uh, there's another thing here which is that
it's not clear to me that polls showing someone
is winning when they're not winning.
Help them to win.
In other words, if you don't want Biden to
win and you see a poll saying he defeat Trump,
doesn't that make you more likely to go and
support Trump so that the pole doesn't become
a reality?
Like maybe, I don't even understand how fake
polling is designed to work, but on every
level that post-hoc rash rationalization makes
no sense.
What's clear is that as of right now, Donald
Trump does have a problem how big of a problem
it is.
We won't know until the debates tart and until
Donald Trump starts actually campaigning in
earnest.